[Music]  our guest of honor father rasputin  gregory  to dance  [Music]  your reputation precedes you  [Music]  uh  [Music]  are you a monk or a ballet dancer are  you waiters or englishman  [Music]  [Music]  i apologize  kingsman world's finest tailor  but now we're going into the spy  business  very clever based on true events  this will not be a war of heroes  [Music]  meet history's most evil legends  [Music]  weakness throwing arm  strength  started world war one  the super spy  mata hari strength  screen presence  weakness  scarves do you forget your manners  guilty as charged  have a crazed monkey  respiratory strength  and weaknesses  [Music]  [Music]  it's time to remind them what the  kingsmen are  [Music]  nobility is born  in blood  [Music]  boys are always so messy  the king's man only in theaters december  22nd  [Music]  you